out the ability to influence and
persuade your pants you can't put
yourself out there into the world great
salespeople understand that it takes
three four or five noes to actually get
to the yes is every sale the same well
only if you're in control see once you
take control of the encounter once you
learn how you can now make every sale
the same what's that belief nation it's
Evan my one word is believe and I
believe in you I believe you have an
amazing gift inside you that I want to
see exploded onto the world now I
started the momentum II series to try to
hang around people who've done a lot
more than us and hopefully by spending
more time with them some of their views
their mindsets their beliefs their way
of thinking seeps into us to help us
become the best version of ourselves so
today we're gonna learn from one of the
best jordan belfort the wolf of Wall
Street and how to master the art of
selling mentor me Jordan
[Music]
you
Warren Buffett was doing the speech of
Bill Gates about maybe ten years ago and
he was asked by a college student what
can we do as students to make ourselves
more valuable in the workplace
so you think Warren Buffett would say
learn how to pick stocks learn how
investments you know whatever you would
say not what he says he says go out and
take a course in sales and cos
allocation day he did Dale Carnegie
James says like there you go now that
point because he took that he said I
took Dale Kearney changement without
back you don't he'd be without that
course yeah he'd be the richest money
manager in Omaha Nebraska then no one
ever heard of yeah Annie met his wife
that way the love is like because
without the ability to influence and
persuade your Kanaks you can't put
yourself out there into the world and be
known for what you really are what sales
really is is the transfer of emotion
that's what's happening when you sell
your transferring emotion and the
primary emotion that you're transferring
is the emotion of certainty in other
words watch this you as a Salesman when
you enter the encounter you have to be
absolutely certain that your product is
the best make sense it's gonna give them
the best benefits out there the best
value proposition and so forth and you
are in this state of absolute certainty
so imagine now we have a continuum of
certainty a line of certainty so we have
this line of certainty and on one side
of the equation we have it's called a1
and the other side we have a 10 so a 10
represents a state of absolute certainty
meaning your prompt is the best thing
since sliced bread it's gonna give them
exactly what they want benefit wise it's
the best deal for the money it's gonna
make them feel the whole thing right it
is just absolutely awesome that's a 10
on the certain skill it is great the
best thing since sliced bread and on the
other end of the spectrum you have
what's called a 1 right which is it's
the worst piece of in the world right
it's crap right your product is terrible
it's not gonna work
okay the benefits don't match up what
they need it's overpriced I didn't want
to be near this piece of crap because I
just feel stupid even buying it or even
thinking about buying it that's a 1
right so here's the first thing you need
to understand that the moment you open
up your mouth to speak as a sales when
you start a sale the question is this
where is the average prospect the person
you're trying to sell to where are they
on the certainty scale at the beginning
anyone know where are they who the [ __ ]
knows you must be in this state of
absolute certainty because what's
happening is this what you're doing when
you're selling is everything that you
say everything that you do every
tonality use every gesture you make
every document you hand them every
phrase that comes out of your mouth are
all designed to do one simple thing to
essentially raise the prospects level of
certainty to as close to his 10 as a
possible that's what you're doing your
the words that you say the the
presentation that you make the tonality
that you use every any document you in
sales aids whatever it might be is all
designed to take them from where they
are on the certainty scale and move to
as close to where you are as possible
essentially you're transferring your
white-hot certainty disowns that a
cooler level at a lower level of
certainty it's almost like this first
law or so I think is actually the second
law of thermodynamics in physics right
under you study physics energy always
flows from hot to cold not the other way
around so you need to be this white-hot
level of certainty it's exerting out of
you every pore that you have and we know
what certainty feels like in sounds like
we intuitively know as salespeople and
our prospects know as well we know when
someone sounds certain and they have
confidence and they're enthusiastic we
know what that looks like
feels like it sounds like let's pretend
this is like the water line in the ocean
here's your water line I'm the world's
worst artist and when you're on the
phone with a client running a straight
line pattern and he's saying no no no no
no no no no no no no you're not like
this it's not going like that what's
happening is this this is oh this is the
water line here right water line okay
this is essentially success when he goes
above the water line and you see it he
says yes what he's saying no he's below
the water line what's happening is this
as you're going you're getting closer
and closer and closer and closer and
right so you don't see the result yet
the same way your guy who's working to
build his business he might not be
making money yet but he's making massive
progress below the water line and all of
a sudden that last pinch of certainty
and the guy says boom you're above the
was that the guy just said yes no he
didn't he was saying yes the whole time
he was getting close yes yes yes to
certain parts of certainty he just
wasn't there on all three ten so he had
lowered his action threshold so what
happens is this if this is the three
tens then lowering someone's actually
especially what you be essentially
lowering the water line so you can
actually increase his certainty lower
the water line and make it easier for
the guy to say yes but let me tell you
something when you are running a
straight line that's let's say minute
one and minute 60 and he closes here it
meant 40 you don't think you're making
progress between 1 and 40 you're making
massive progress it's just below the
water line this is why great fails
people understand that it takes 3 4 or 5
knows to actually get to the yes what no
is it's almost a euphemism for saying
what no means I am NOT certain that's
all it means
when someone says let me call you back
let me think about it I want to talk to
my wife or just plain old no
it just means I am NOT certain every
sale is the same they like what
everything I got the looks right those
crazy looks with every cells not the
same every I said guys every sale is the
same and then I said watch and his
visual popped in my mind it's a straight
line as for the very first time I drew
this long thin line on the center of the
board it was old leaving a longer boy to
boys right
I said this is your open I said this is
your clothes I said in every once in a
while back when you were selling penny
stocks you get one of these lay down
clients we could call them wear
everything that you say and everything
that you do the clients like saying yes
yes yes yes from the very beginning all
the way to the end when you ask for the
order for the first we said yeah great
how do I pay right that perfect lay down
sale now I'm sure we you all get them
every once in a while we get one of
those people who seems to be almost
pre-sold before they even enter your
funnel that's almost soul right you're
saying they agree with you the whole
time perfect lay down sale but that is
the exception to the rule most of the
time so you want it this sort so those a
straight-line sale is the perfect lay
down sale when everything that you say
and everything that you do the client
agreed they're on board the whole way
through and you asked for the order the
first and they left all your jokes the
whole you get it and perfect sale you
ask you till I said yes great how do I
pay that's a perfect straight line shell
but most of time that's not the way it
goes the typical client wants to go off
the line they have questions they
interrupt of the objections so they try
to take you off floor I took it at the
price of tea in China right you want to
keep them on the line so what we have is
these healthy boundaries above and below
the line when you're inside these
boundaries you're in control of the sale
these are the healthy boundaries above
and below the line because even when
myself very seldom is I man I have
anymore lay down sales than anybody else
I have the same as anybody else but is
this healthy boundary I don't let it
fail spiral out of control because you
go off here outside the values off the
freakin Pluto right or your anus
not a good place to be for most of us at
least right I don't judge okay Pluto or
Uranus right this is out of control
where you ask someone a question about
your qualifying question to try and
gather intelligence right and they might
start answer your question the right way
but next things only spiral off they
talk about the price of tea in China
okay in most people the problem that
they have most sales rule is that when
someone starts to spiral out and talk
about nonsense you'll jump right into
the nightmare cuz you're the waters woah
let me get into reporting just not talk
with them and that's not rapport because
the sooner you do that they realize
they're in control the sale they will
assume control of sale and once that
happens nothing good happens besides the
fact that you're branded as a novice not
as an expert I said guys let me tell you
when you're calling rich people even
poor people matter who you're calling
you got four seconds that's all you have
you have four seconds to establish three
crucial things or else you're done you
can't close anybody because they'll take
control of the sale
and once they take control of the sale
it's like you're almost like an out
match boxer covering up some mobile
blows like imagine walking in through
the green with Mike Tyson right and he's
barrage you're just covering up because
he's in control and you get knocked out
of anyone so that's what's happening to
my guys they're getting knocked out they
were losing control right out of the
gate because they were not being
perceived as V three-phase let me tell
you exactly what they are number one in
the first four seconds you must be
perceived as number one being sharp as a
task that you're sharp and on the ball
number two that you're enthusiastic is
held in thews II asked his health Uzi
azzam must be good and number three and
most important of all I'm an expert in
my field you're an expert in your field
they got four seconds to establish those
three crucial or you're done because if
you don't establish them see what they
roll up to what they chunk up to is
essentially that you're a person worth
listening to you're worth listening to
and even higher so close you could help
them
achieve their goals help them get what
they want people don't listen to you get
what you want
they do it because I get what they want
Sharp's attack and through meeting sharp
on the ball right not a time waster to
enthusiastic so now I'm not saying so
some people say oh come on people
they see through that infusion no they
don't I'm not talking about over-the-top
oh my god my pride that's [ __ ] I'm
talking about bottled enthusiasm below
the surface it's a it could be a whisper
it's a certain way of talking a certain
way of caring ism where they could just
tell it you are dead serious about what
you have your confidence you it's a way
of speaking it's not yelling and it's
not talking fast I'm talking fast
knuckles I have an hour right to get
eight hours information so I'm talking
about if i was selling I'd be speaking
slowly succinctly and I had that bottled
enthusiam just below the surface and
your gut it's about to bubble over but
it never bubbles over because you're in
control cuz you're an expert and when
you have that way of speaking I'll
explain how in a few minutes it's
infectious people want to hear more
they're intoxicated by it it transfers
to someone else it's an emotional
feeling they get and of course an expert
in your field number three well listen
here's the bottom line we have been
conditioned
since we're yay big to defer and respect
experts and figures of authority
you know don't buck Authority respect
your elders you know you were trained as
a kid you went to the doctor right and
the doctor asked you questions you
didn't say what's your education he done
you didn't ask him questions back you
saw his diploma on the wall he had a
white coat he had a stethoscope he was a
doctor your parents explained this man's
gone through special education he's an
expert in his field he's going to heal
you he get it is a specialist and you
respected him and you didn't you
answered his question fully and honestly
now I'm sure you've all been probably
later on in life when they tried to pull
the old let me get the nurse's assistant
to ask you two questions you know like
yeah you I'll answer in the done you'll
answer them in a be one word you're not
gonna even nearly as forthright with the
practitioner as the bathrooms of why
because you've been conditioned and they
violate they might be just as competent
if not more at taking notes and doing a
a certain through that triage but when
that bastard walked in who he's a doctor
that's an expert in this field
if you don't establish these three
things you're fighting a massive uphill
battle because now they are in control
the encounter and good luck see is every
cell the same well only if you're in
control see once you take control of the
encounter once you learn how you can now
make every sale the same Bandler didn't
do these experiments with people with
matching and mirroring and when you
mirror somebody you get into massive
rapport with them the less offensive way
is not to mirror but to match and that
means don't and they go sit down on a
stool like this okay and they you know
cross their arms you don't like as
they're doing it crossed if you're armed
you know you wait a few seconds jiggle
around then you cross your arms okay if
someone sit with their legs crossed okay
then you wait a few seconds and you
cross your legs and you settle into the
same posture that the other person is
this is usually hugely powerful for
gaining a reformed person don't
underestimate this it operates in a
level you can't quite grasp it's it's an
unconscious level look at the opposite
is to understand let's say you walk in
someplace and someone's flailing their
arms about they're just out of but
you're in a calm state and they're in
opposites think they're all agitated
how do you feel about that person out of
a port right you're instantly you know
you're you're standoffish right well
just imagine the opposite about the
polar opposite would be someone who
moves just like you someone who speaks
just like you so one who vibrates at the
precise level and frequency that you do
that's what matching and mirroring is
all about to get into them in their
world to enter at the same level and to
slowly move that level up or down
depending on what part of the
presentation or clothes you're at to
create the appropriate emotion that
allows them to make the right decision
which is to buy your product that's body
language
angry pissed-off negative unrest social
state you can't do anything well you've
got one of those days for instance where
everything you're doing you're like I
can't believe I said that I can't
believe I did that I'm such a fool right
yeah that day we've all had that day
yeah next day similar situation you're
like wow you know that was me I did a
really great job right you're perfect so
one day you're brilliant next day same
situation you're brutal that's not
talent that's not ability that's the
state that you're in so the key to
success is not just a to have your
vision but to be able to manage the way
you feel in the moment now if you're a
parent what's the most resourceful state
patience if you're a businessman looking
to make money on Wall Street it's
probably certainty yeah more courage
because fear is the worst emotion of all
for being a traitor on Wall Street so
every business has different states that
you need to master now in most
businesses in matters of wealth is
straight three states that you need to
master you're the trigger and a moment's
notice and it's easy to do once you
learn out we're just gonna teach people
hey and number one is certainty to be
certain about what you're doing the
second one is clarity to be clear it's
not to be overwhelmed with you the
office will be overwhelmed and the third
is courage is to have a conviction
to know that you might not be right all
the time but you can exact let fear stop
because if there's one distinction that
between the wealthy people of the world
and the pulpit of the world is that
wealthy people act in the face of fear
while poor people run away from favorite
now I've got a special jordan belfort
bonus sales tip for you but before that
the question of the day today is has
this video motivated you to go out and
want to sell more give me a yes or no
leave it down in the comments below
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one where it
is much love
I'll see you soon
you ended up at this firm
it was oak what was it oh crap okay
little firm called the Investor Center
which is a penny stock firm right and
that was where I you know it was really
first night ever sold stock and I became
the top broker the first day just broke
all the records really in the first day
you broke all the right your first day
yeah yeah so you're a bore
do you think you're a born salesman yeah
for sure I am open and there are people
out there will born closers one salesman
far if you would do there are some when
that really means though what does it
mean to be a born salesman what it means
is that you're actually running the
strategy automatically inside usually
good you're still following this script
but it comes natural automatically so
you but you don't realize it but you are
following a certain protocol that gets
you to the same outcome every time so
that's really what it born closers so
for those people watching that our
entrepreneurs want to learn sales what
did you do in that first day that you
basically became a top sales in like was
there we're gonna talk more about your
whole sales straight-line formula but
first day you didn't have time to
implement a whole script what do you do
that most people don't do is it your
tonality that's one of the things body
language tonality taking people through
features not just features but benefits
according I think you did that first day
well in fact I see one of the
interesting things you say you would you
have time to put the other scripts in
fact I did oh you did oh yeah day one I
took three hours to write one so yeah I
would never this is something
interesting thing had many years layers
is relevant is that when I was tested by
some psychologists not my ability to
close they put me through a whole
battery of these weird tests and one of
them was a mock sale where I had to
close someone in a investment type of
situation that was being filled was
there like so me this pants they handed
me up like a little sort of us some
information on the dairy industry and I
have to then convince someone to so I
open up an account at a firm to manage
the money for the dairy industry right
okay so they handed out about 10-12
pages of information right and they said
take as much time as you want and you
know just I said let's see you closed
this guy right so I start reading I'm
reading it and I'm reading right I start
writing down my thoughts now 30 minutes
later they knock on the door
like ya said give me more time yeah just
give me another 30 bits I said okay no
problem
30 minutes goes by they come back I said
just meet another 20 minutes they said
no problem take 20 more minutes
I said give me 15 more minutes right
anyway after about two hours I said I'm
ready and I wrote myself a really really
not an exact script but pretty close to
a really killer script with so if you
know how I would actually engineer the
sail from storm there's so many stocks
no canals recent maybe oh really
okay this is right is relevant now this
is in nineteen it's like I think the
2010 at this Apple okay
with psychologists being Phil okay this
is the later John died he was an actor
and he was supposed to be the CEO of a
dairy company and I was supposed to
close him so we go through this whole
thing I introduced myself and I we go
for this back and forth back and forth
and they're filming the whole thing and
after about 15 minutes the guy just he's
like okay fine I'll open up an account
and he starts laughing his ass off so
I'm like what's so funny
psychologists come and they say we told
him under no circumstances should he say
yes yeah within 15 minutes yet no he
said yes I don't get it he said I said
well you don't want I got the guy into a
situation did it make sense to say no he
said well here's the weird thing we've
tested a hundred other people in sales
and no one ever spent more than five
minutes reading the material huh you
spent so apparation it's some simple
fundamental teach equip are the straight
line is about strategic preparation
meeting that you don't you know what was
my overriding concept is every sales the
same right yes and that would seem to be
counterintuitive yes because everyone
has different needs different belief
systems right different outcomes real
but the truth is that every sale is the
same yes and I'll explain that little
bit later on in the interview but it
starts with your ability to essentially
make an airtight case to someone yes on
both illogical
and the right yeah about you know
essentially why you're right you could
want them to do whatever you want them
to why does it make sense right yes and
it's got to be an airtight case and then
you have to be able to also accomplish
other things as well so there's two ways
to go about that one is still wing it
which you could might be able to do if
you're really really great or you can
write it down plan it out I mean the
second one is where you really start to
bring your averages of tremendous easel
I'm a big believer in strategic
preparation raise your
standard Apple at the core its core
value is that we believe that people
need passion can change the way people
now one drop of myself work depends on
your disciplines to me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten roses success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link the description for details